so so here's here's what i want to point
out going back to the conversation about
energy now that i have this article from
la
from a couple almost two years ago now
yeah it's from yahoo news
actually it's from the national review
aoc's chief of staff admits
the green new deal is not about climate
change
this is important context i know it's an
old story but considering the
conversation happening around texas
right now so for those of you that are
watching
if you get someone who says see aoc says
this is why we need a green new deal
okay all right that's the argument show
them this clip
this is what we have sciket chakrabarty
aoc's former chief of staff said
that addressing climate change was not
okaza cortez's top priority in proposing
the green new deal during a meeting with
washington governor jay inslee
quote the interesting thing about the
green new deal is
it wasn't originally a climate thing at
all this is what chakra body said to
inslee's climate director sam
ricketts he said uh do you do you guys
think of it as a climate thing
because we really think of it as a how
do you change the entire economy thing
the green new deal proposed earlier this
year by ocasio-cortez and senator ed
markey
would transition the u.s economy
entirely away from fossil fuels within
10 years
while simultaneously providing a federal
jobs and health care guarantee
it would also according to its
proponents advanced social economic
racial regional and gender-based
justice and equality in cooperative and
public ownership
all told all told the proposal will cost
up to 93 trillion dollars in new
government spending over 10 years yadda
yadda we get it okay
to put it simply let me ask you a
question a rhetorical question
i'll i'll just reframe it actually if
someone came to me and said
do you think we should allocate taxpayer
funds towards
investing in new energy technologies in
an effort to offset carbon emissions
i would say yes if someone say so all of
a sudden you say yes they say
boom you support the green new deal okay
that sounds good to me
and that's what they asked people what
they did not ask them was the actual
contents of the green new deal
do you support the largest transfer of
power to the government
economic uh power and economic control
to the government
in order to ensure racial uh you know
racial
and gender-based equity and guaranteed
housing and healthcare
that has nothing to do with the
environment that's going to dramatically
drop the amount of people who agree with
that last point
chakra bardi said it was about changing
the economy
it's a new deal with green just jammed
in there
to use environmentalism as a
manipulation because when i read that
bill
i was looking for a legitimate
resolution that said
we're going to allocate x amount of
funds towards fusion we're going to
allocate x amount of funds towards
nuclear development which i knew they
would never do and we're going to
allocate x amount of funds towards
carbon capture and i'd be like let's
let's technology it's awesome man let's
fund technology
they didn't they said we're going to
guarantee health care to people of color
and i'm like okay
how about the line we're going to
guarantee income for those unwilling to
work
they must have read that and said wow
and they and they had to remove that
in panic and then try and deny it just
imagine
imagine the stupidity of someone who
says we are going to
get all fossil fuels in 10 years someone
who says that
just literally doesn't know how the
world works right it just does anytime
you say like
would you support this outcome that's
moronic like
would you support daniel winning the
race yeah sure
well in that case let me take any means
necessary to make it happen thank you
that's basically the
new deal so they kill the three of them
and then i will then
automatically you will win so so daniel
look look around the room
is there anything in this room that was
created without
fossil fuels it's not possible or if it
doesn't if it doesn't
contain a fossil fuel it was only
created
at a price point that you could afford
to put it in this room
because fossil fuel made it right the
wood that was
milled you could afford to buy because
it was
the trees were harvested they were
transported they were cut
they were brought to your home depot all
at a price point you could afford and
that's what's beautiful about the free
market system
it takes the most amount of goods and
lowers it to the lowest cost imaginable
and and just done a quick little note
right
to not to be political but the last four
years trump is an oil guy trump is an
only guy he supports big oil
boy for a guy who supports big oil oil
prices were pretty
damn low right the oil companies
want to make profit off of volume they
were oil was at an
even before covid oil prices were low
because they were producing more of it
the industry the free market wants to
produce more things at a lower price
point because
more people can buy it so let's let's
talk about price point and there's good
there's the story from way back when one
man's nearly impossible quest to make a
toaster from
scratch now what does it mean from
scratch i'm not talking about and they
mentioned this in the article a guy
going to radio
shack or home depot whatever you buy
components i need some wire
i need some some metal no no he
literally wanted to make every single
part of it the springs
everything from the ground up guess what
he could not do it
he the one thing he couldn't do was
plastic i watched this video on it
he couldn't do plastic so he ended up
mining the plastic he went and found
some and then melted it down
and all in all the toaster worked for i
think about 20 seconds before it broke
toasters cost what 10 bucks yeah for the
average person
working at mcdonald's takes about an
hour well after tax is about an hour and
a half two hours
and then you get a toaster this guy
could not make
the fact that we have this massive
industry
all of it 190 something percent fueled
by fossil fuels means that you can have
these things people cannot make on their
own
not only so the interesting thing about
it was plastics so
he couldn't he couldn't make it if he
wanted to he could do the metal he did
everything else but he couldn't actually
make the plastic which is funny because
you know fossil fuel-based for the most
part petrochemicals and things like that
think about you you brought this up
before the show ham sandwiches yeah
you want you want to tell the ham
sandwich story yeah it was similar to
that and and i have to find i don't
remember where i read it but it was a
guy
who it was i forget where it was a guy
who wanted to make a ham sandwich same
idea though
every component he wanted to make he
wanted to grow the wheat
to make the bread he wanted to grow the
pig to make the ham
it took him years and it cost him i
think the price point was like a
thousand dollars where he laughed and
said
i can go to the store and buy this ham
sandwich for four bucks or i could make
it on my own and it's a thousand dollars
and
years to make it happen again the beauty
of the free market i i recently made
uh with some friends from scratch some
general sews chicken
oh and i was looking at the ingredients
and i was like
the amount of things that had to be
pulled together to make this
would have been like one of the
manhattan project like 2000 years ago
if you gave them that recipe they'd be
like what we have to get all of these
things to make this
that's not possible and and what amazes
me about the aocs of the world of of the
haughtiness sometimes of our elite is
the average person in america right now
the average person has the greatest
quality of life in the history of
mankind
you you find people who don't make an
awful lot of money who will say things
like oh you know i really like craft
beer and i like to get my craft beer
from this place
a generation ago we all drank our
our parents and my parents your
grandparents they drank schlitz
right because that's what was available
and now you're dragging on schlitz i
know i'm just saying
there were four or five brands in that
right and now we find people who
who because we have created such
prosperity and that
comes from an abundance of energy to go
back to the very first question why is
there a food shortage in texas
there's an energy shortage where is
there the most poverty in the world
where there's no energy
sub-saharan africa southeast asia where
is there the most pollution
and and and despair and the worst
quality of life
the same countries energy gives us
prosperity it gives us
the and if americans are willing to
compromise their quality of life for the
environment
then i'm not going to stop them from
doing it but they need to know that is
what is on the line and to say we're
going to have a green new deal
but we're going to continue with all of
this is just a lie there's a balance
because i went to south america to
iquitos in northeast peru which is like
the last big city before you get into
the jungle and
uh honda basically got their tentacles
and aquitos and started
selling them these tuk-tuks these like
three-wheel cars and basically brand
them all honda and they're they use
like gas engines all of them so there's
like thousands tens and hundreds of
thousands of these
just pouring black smoke into the air it
smells
disgusting it's also considered the
dirtiest city on the planet
um that's because it's just all running
off gas with no carbon capture
taken into consideration so there's
about we need to learn how to
use it absolutely we need a balance
and and and i would argue that we have
allowed ourselves to have this binary
mentality we either love the earth or we
want to pollute it with fossil fuels
and i think they go hand in hand i look
at this country
which is a very big fossil fuel consumer
and our air
our water quality we are not a dirty
country could we be cleaner of course we
could be cleaner right i don't want to
become this city in
peru i don't want to become that
but we're not there and so like we said
with the straw ban
we are chastising ourselves and
compromising our quality of life
for the sins committed by other
countries for the pollution created by
china for the
pollution created by indonesia and india
um
when are we going to stand up and say
you know what we don't throw i i grew up
in rockaway as
i was saying earlier on the beach i've
been to lots of different beaches in
this country i've never seen
plastic strewn all over the place we
don't pollute our oceans in america
why are we culpable because greta phone
you pronounce it differently than i do
tells us well it's our fault there's
plastic in the ocean
yeah i think the h is silent is it i'm
pretty sure it's tuned i'm tired of
us being being having to compromise our
quality of life
for the sins committed by other
countries because there are countries
committing
great sins against the environment we're
going to find out that the carbon
dioxide in the air is valuable like a
natural resource to reuse and the
plastic in the ocean is insanely
valuable when you can melt it down or
break it down with fungus and bacteria
to turn it into sugar and reuse it it's
going to be worth
its weight in gold so if china wants to
throw it into the ocean so that we can
recapture it i'm totally into it just
give it about 15 years
carbon capture technology converting the
carbon in the air to graphene like you
were mentioning i think is going to
become lucrative
yeah and i think then we're going to
have an inverse problem where it's like
too much carbon is being taken like
and the plants will be suffering so
we're going to need to balance out that
it's true
we can't mine it at all out of the air
graphene has long been hailed as this
wonder
material that's going to revolutionize
everything superconductor materials what
is it like you crisscross it it becomes
a superconductor
yeah so twist it something like that
like we were talking about it
and there's a lot of amazing properties
that's like super strong
well you need carbon for that and if you
you mentioned this earlier in the show
that they're going to capture it from
the air
to make graphene graphene is pure carbon
so you get the carbon dioxide out of the
air and you put it on palladium
apparently the same metal that used for
cold fusion the palladium
it's incredible metal by the way um and
i didn't get through the article with
the process
earlier in 50 to 100 years when they're
like you know global cooling
catastrophe because too much carbon is
being extracted
by these graphene manufacturing plants
i'm sure they'll find something to be
you know there's articles going back to
the 70s obviously for the global cooling
this my favorite article of all um which
is recirculated a lot is the uh the un
report of 1989 saying we had 10 years to
fix climate change
and if not the maldives would be
underwater within 30 years
what about the 70s the global cooling
crisis yeah exactly you know
but i again i also think like i said
earlier i don't like
well i don't like i don't trust the
press and i also don't like government
and i
my whole life i've been told between
killer bees and swine flu and bird flu
and this pandemic everything's going to
kill me every five seconds we're always
told we're gonna die this whole like
slow death thing is driving
i think it's a fear thing because we're
coming out of the last ice age right now
that's the research shows we're in a
what is it called um
glaciation period where everything's
melting all the ice caps are going to
melt back to normal
we're out of the ice age and the real
fear is an asteroid impact
and a massive global flood not a slow
raise in the sea level it doesn't happen
like that it happens in jolts and jerks
so we got to prevent
and be prepared for that kind of thing
well we we need a we need to understand
a lot of things
it's it's not always you know so
strongly on one
side that there's going to be a solution
on you know there are some legitimate
issues that we do need to take care of
especially with the environment
especially with china especially with
other third world developing countries
especially things that we could also do
better and we should strive to do better
but we're not going to be doing better
when we're going to be punishing people
for living their lives
and doing it radically and listening to
people like alexandria ocasio-cortez
that literally said the world will end
in 12 years if climate change is not
addressed
and i i called my organization power the
future for a reason because i do believe
our future is better and brighter and
has fewer emissions etc etc but the
geniuses who are thinking about this and
and the conversations we're having the
people who are going to laboratories and
factories and experimenting
are using conventional energy and if we
[ __ ] our conventional energy now
we are crippling our future those people
have to drive
they have to turn on lights they have to
run big machines so let's not punish
ourselves
now for the hope of a better tomorrow
you know who's not crippling their
energy
china that's right dog look at the coal
plants that build it nor is russia
right if anything russia is laughing
itself silly so what you're saying is
that greta tunberg is working for the
russians to
to hurt america i am saying that there
is that this is newtonian
and there is always an an opposite
effect
and and by punishing american fossil
fuels
other people going to prosper look
they're only certain with geology as
such
that only certain countries have oil and
gas i i
wish they were all america in canada
because we're great but the other ones
are the saudis the omanis the yemenis
the russians they're not the the
venezuelans they're not the greatest
regimes on earth i heard a really
horrifying point i'm not the iranians i
don't remember who said it may have been
mike cernovich he said something like or
someone said
if you think the middle east is be is
destabilized now
wait until we discontinue use of fossil
fuels and then see what happens
what little is helping to stabilize that
area is
the desire for for profit and industry
and the access to this resource
once no one cares about that anymore
then fighting is going to be for just
just un unfettered uncontrolled yeah
although like you said that pipeline is
all about moving moving fossil fuels so
if you need it we may not have to fight
over that but it would be very different
i'd imagine
yeah yeah they don't want to uh to pay
the high prices to russia anymore
so they want this pipeline built and
it's resulting in chaos
i've been thinking about if we were to
melt all the ice the countries that
would
massively profit or canada russia i
don't know how it does china is it
super far north up where china no no
russia is to the north
um russia it's russia russia russia
make massive amounts of money when all
that well then all that isis gone in
siberia
and up there and they already they
already want to start drilling and so
there's now
you know canada and greenland is gonna
be fascinating with no ice
and we almost bought it right our last
president tried to buy it for
i forget he wanted to put that casino in
there and you know if you get the price
tag it wasn't much you know we all could
have done a paypal
go fund me and who owns greenland is it
uh denmark
denmark oh my gosh wow
it's funny because denmark's like pretty
tiny like in europe
but it's like they have green land it's
massive it's a whole lot of ice though
you know i i will say this um the ice on
greenland is ice that is not displacing
water
so they say when that melts it will
change the salinity levels the flow
and potentially the the water the ocean
levels themselves yeah
it melts on the inside and then it
breaks and floods and causes like a dead
zone of lack of salt water all this
fresh water
my question is like why are these ultra
elites buying beachfront properties
no no but this is this it's funny but
like i i got someone sent me a video
where a guy said that he could debunk
climate change with one simple fact
and then he brought up that some global
elite like i don't know who
who was bought florida beachfront
property
and he said how is that possible that
you have these people saying all this
because all this is going to happen and
they just made a 30-year investment
on waterfront property he said there's
another video someone sent me where a
guy talks about how
if this was true no bank would issue a
loan to
anyone buying or building on beach
fronts but they don't
care why is that but just to finish this
the argument from the left is just
simply because people don't care yeah
that's a problem or they don't believe
because even as as you have now called
them our lord and savior bill gates
in his cnn interview on sunday said you
know we have 30 years
to fix this problem well aoc two years
ago said we had 10 years
at the at the presidential debates the
democrat primaries um
uh andrew yang said we have no time it's
already here
we should start moving people to higher
ground remember that
the floridians were like oh boy pack
your bags kids i guess
you know we're moving somewhere right so
they know that this timeline is a joke
bill gates says 30 years aoc says eight
the legitimate scientists though not the
politicians not the politicos or the
people trying to make money
we'll tell you it's a lot longer than
that right so there's a meteorologist
who frequently would debunk
aoc saying climate climate change and
carbon emissions they're serious
problems
we need to solve for these problems ten
years that's not true
yeah these people are just you know
pushing trying to push you and scare you
and what's going to happen in say it's
50 years are we going to be as warm as
we were
in the 1640s when england had very
prosperous vineyards right we're going
to be warmer
well we were warmer during the height of
the renaissance
were we all dying are we all under water
you know what i mean like we came out of
the black plague and
so yeah i don't know what the
consequences of of global warming are i
just hear it's catastrophe
all i know is that beneath the frost of
greenland
are an awful lot of trees and all i know
is that when you go through the sands of
saudi arabia
there's an awful lot of seashells right
i mean that's ocean sand
from the last global yes so so we had
nothing to do with that
i i think it's very hard to think that
we have something to do with what's
happening now thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you